joining me now is louisiana senator john
kennedy senator great to see you tonight
we know that china has a recording and a
transcript of all these calls lord knows
what milia said in other calls
just as trump released the call with the
ukrainian president
what has to be done here given the
gravity of the situation
well first large just one point of view
roses are red
political love is fake
washington
weddings are just funerals with cake
i know president biden has said he will
stand behind and stands behind general
milley
and maybe that's true for the short term
but i'm going to give you even odds that
eventually
the white house throws him under the bus
because the white house desperately
needs someone besides president biden on
which to blame
the the stunning incompetence in
afghanistan
now to answer your question
even duct tape can't fix stupid
if
if general milley had these
communications
with the communist party of china
he's a smoke turkey
and he ought to be
if general milley had these
communications with the communist party
of china
and if in the future he wishes to
comment on america's national security
he should raise his hand and put it over
his mouth
america is not myanmar america is not
guinea
if it's true
general miller if it's true general
milley broke the chain of command but
much worse he broke the inviolate rule
of civilian control of the military
and every defender
democrat or republican
of constitutional government should be
outraged
well tonight
we hit the shot
let me just jump in here for a moment
senator tonight senator mike pompeo and
former dni radcliff both indicated
that they weren't aware of this call
and it didn't go through regular order i
mean if you're going to start doing
freelance foreign policy the chairman of
the joint chiefs
the secretary of state was not aware of
this and also was not aware of any
impending attack that the administration
was going to launch willy-nilly against
china at any period of time
so what we know is that he did have
these offline conversations is that not
enough
regardless of even the contents of the
conversations which i think he's
quibbling about some of the lines but
isn't that enough
that he has to go because of the clear
and present danger that he
presents to the country right now
well unelected generals
do not to get to have their own personal
foreign policies
and i think the general has conceded
that he did have communications
with the chinese communist party and its
military wing we need to see a
transcript and
the white house needs to release that
transcript
they don't need to release it in a
classified setting they need to release
it in an unclassified setting with as
minimal
number of redactions as possible
this is serious this is more than just
insubordination
as a people we've decided that we want
to to maintain a wall between
our commander-in-chief who must be a
civilian it's the president of the
united states who is duly elected
a wall between the president and the
military
and there's a reason for that
go look at myanmar go look at guinea
right now well by the way on the subject
of the treasury course throughout the
world on the transcript question senator
um i want to get your reaction to this
uh comment by the spokesman
at the pentagon john kirby watch
when the chairman or the secretary
they interact with their counterparts
it's a function of the job they have to
do that now is every single interaction
written down and sent in a memo probably
not
so senator they really want us to
believe that there are no records at all
no notes kept of milly's conversations
with china and other foreign countries i
mean if the intelligence community was
brought in on this
we know they make transcripts of these
calls with with our most serious
adversary two top level officials
there's no transcript they were they
were taping mike mike flynn weren't they
well you know good try guys let's see
the transcript we all know it exists
the nsa has it they don't have it the
cia has it
uh i don't want to see the notes though
if they have the notes will be helpful
we need to see the transcript so senator
it's your prediction that
even though they seem somewhat dug in
today about millie
that
the pressure will stay on from you guys
in the senate mcconnell etc
and that'll be enough to push him out
that's your prediction well i i just
look i could be wrong but i just think
it's a practical matter
you can run but you can't hide i would
say to the white house
from the stunning incompetence of
afghanistan yeah we have 13 people dead
13 soldiers dead in marines and marines
dead and uh in afghanistan no one was
fired
i know it's the damage done
to our foreign policy to the americans
left behind to our afghan friends left
behind all of our nato allies
uh that's going to take years to try to
repair
and i think the white house is looking
for someone on which to blame this
and uh general milley is there
and i i you know i'm not saying i agree
with it but i think eventually they're
going to push him in front of the bus
all right senator great to see you
tonight masking tape and all those
analogies are great hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else